voilà alors une trentaine d'heures après
ces attaques on est en mesure maintenant
de reconstituer assez précisément le
déroulement des événements en clair le
détournement concertée pratiquement
simultanée de quatre avions de ligne
transformé donc en bombes volantes
dominique verdeilhan agnès garde peur
sur la ville un avion survole manhattan
un caméraman saisit alors cette image
hors du commun
un boeing 767 vient de percuter l'un des
building du world trade center
la tour est en flammes les secours
s'organisent accidents aériens ou
attentats l'amérique l'ignorent encore à
8h56 le vol 11 d'american airlines parti
de boston n'atteindra jamais los angeles
à son bord 80 passagers et 11 membres
d'équipage
18 minutes plus tard alors que les
télévisions du monde entier ont
interrompu leurs programmes
un deuxième avion s'encastre à son tour
dans l'autre building un second crash
lui aussi filmé par de nombreuses
caméras
[Applaudissements]
le vol 77 d'american airlines parti de
washington n'arrivera jamais à los
angeles à son bord 58 passagers
six membres d'équipage new york est
plongé dans un film catastrophe les
secours assistent impuissants à des
scènes d'horreur à certaines fenêtres
des employés font des signes désespérés
dérisoire d'autres choisissent le grand
saut
[Rires]
scènes d'exode de panique la thèse de
l'attentât terroriste ne fait aucun
doute sur leur écran de contrôle les
aiguilleurs du ciel ont été témoins des
deux détournements des boeing d'american
airlines
les équipages ont été probablement
neutraliser transformant les deux
appareils en avion kamikaze en bombes
volantes george bush s'adresse aux
américains le terrorisme contre notre
nation ne réussira pas maintenant je
vous propose deux jeunes dans ces
moments de silence
que dieu bénisse les victimes et leurs
familles merci quinze minutes plus tard
nouveau scénario catastrophe cette fois
c'est washington qui est la cible le
pentagone est en flammes
percuté par le vol 175 d'unités rain à
son bord 56 passagers neuf membres
d'équipage
à 10h05 alors qu'un journaliste
s'apprête à intervenir à l'antenne
la première tour s'effondre
23 minutes plus tard même vision
d'horreur les 110 étages de la seconde
tour s'encastre les uns dans les autres
plus de trente mille personnes sont
prisonnières du béton
une partie de new york n'est plus que
poussière est grave
aucune trace de carlingue un trou béant
dans un bois près de pittsburgh le vol
93 d'united airlines en direction de san
francisco s'est crashé à l'ambiance
ville à son bord 38 passagers et sept
membres d'équipage
les passagers auraient peut être résisté
aux pirates de l'air empêchant ainsi que
l'avion ne s'écrase sur corde évident
fragilisé par l'effondrement des deux
tours un immeuble s'effondre en fin
d'après midi
hier soir le soleil couchant ne se
reflétait plus dans le world trade
center de new york et donc